well denise clark county is now one step
closer in getting members of the general
public vaccinated from the coronavirus
today the county's first mega
vaccination site was
in operation ahead of opening up to the
general public
joe mohler was there to get a tour of
the facility he's live outside of
cashman center right now
with what you need to know joe
brian this site will be by appointment
only clark county officials hope to
administer thousands of doses every
single day
today was the trial run before they open
to the public tomorrow now let's go
ahead and take a look at the video from
inside
earlier today through that walk through
today roughly 1 000 vaccines were
administered to critical workers
and people who were set to work this
site today was the pilot program used to
get their system running and to figure
out what
changes need to be made tomorrow they
expect to have the first
people from the public which now
includes people over the age of 70.
they've identified individuals to fill
spots over the next few days
the appointment system is all done
online the big thing is
we want you to know that we're going to
work through the tears and we're going
to make sure that we're going to get
through the public as fast as we can
this is the start
of a big step towards us getting back to
what our original normalcy was
now the site will be open seven days a
week when you come you will fill out
what is called the vaccine
administration record with a few
questions before getting the shot
they hope to have that form online as
well you will need to
be patient though until they get a good
flow going the process could take up to
a few hours so make sure you set aside
enough time
at first they expect to administer two
thousand doses a day and eventually
getting up to four thousand now again
this is
all done by appointment only there are
no walk-ups
we were beginning questions about the
website where you do book these
appointments it was down because so many
people were trying to get on there
and make an appointment we actually just
spoke to a couple who stopped by here
just to see the site before their
appointment on monday they said they
spent several hours last night
but they were happy they were able to
get through and make their appointment
for monday reporting live here at
cashman center jim mullen 8 news now